let's talk a little bit about how
americans are feeling about their lives
in the nearly eight years since
president obama was elected to office
there's new gallup data released this
week and this is really relevant because
donald trump has been running a campaign
of fear
based on his assertion that everything's
a disaster right now okay what do we
know from the gallup survey well in 2008
fewer than half of americans said that
their life was good enough to be
considered thriving
that has gone up to 55.4 percent who now
say they believe they are on they are
thriving in 2016 that is on pace to be
the highest in the nine years that
gallup and healthways have tracked that
question not only this when you look at
members of different ethnic and racial
groups
both whites
blacks hispanics and asians who consider
themselves to be thriving have increased
during the era of president obama the
percentage of blacks who consider
themselves to be thriving has gone up by
six percentage points as has the
percentage of whites and hispanics who
believe they are thriving asians who
consider themselves to be thriving have
also gone up by 10 points and this is
based on
how respondents rate their lives in a
variety of different areas and you can
look at the methodology here's the point
i want to discuss
the campaign of trump is based around
things are terrible
because of president obama and they'll
be even worse under hillary clinton
these gallup results results rachel
don't tell us every individual in the
u.s is thriving we have poverty we have
unemployment we have lack of access to
health care we have income inequality
there's no shortage of problems in this
country but on the whole
in every way it is not accurate to say
that people are now worse off and
particularly donald trump talks about
the blacks and the hispanics are extra
worse off
they have seen
a sort of parallel increase in
thriving
uh that mirrors what white people have
experienced so when you're starting from
a flawed
uh uh
of sort of a starting line
the entire race is going to be misjudged
and misunderstood
right and it's interesting also if you
start kind of comparing the the tactics
of obama and trump in terms of kind of
their their presidential crusade okay so
if you're looking at trump someone who
has this fear-mongering and kind of
playing on kind of the deepest and
darkest fears and insecurities of
individuals and then you kind of have
the antithesis of that which is obama
who for lack of a a more cliche saying
the hope and the change even though some
say he didn't really change all that he
ran on that whatever you think he did
run on the positive message exactly and
so it's interesting to look at what what
type of voter and especially what age
that appeals to because if you're
looking at trump's policies okay and
that's kind of going more towards the
older population and then you're looking
at obama who's who has this hope and
change that's appealing more to younger
voters it kind of brings up an
interesting and interesting point saying
okay so what are they interested in and
what is drawing in certain ages and
populations this is a sort of causation
correlation chicken egg scenario which
is trump has a disproportionately older
support base than does hillary clinton
younger voters much more likely to
support hillary clinton older voters
much more likely to support donald trump
is hillary using a more positive message
and trump using a message of fear
because they already know that those
messages are more likely to appeal to
the groups that they are already in
favor with are they more in favor with
those groups because they are choosing
those messages or what is causing what
really really interesting question which
we will continue to cover but
objectively speaking by and large on
average the situation for people in this
country has improved under president
obama